has been messing around in ukraine over
there
but you on the other hand
set your son over there you're you're
selling access to the president just
like he was
so you're a damn liar man that's not
true and no one has ever said that no
one approved that
you said i set up my son to work in an
oil company didn't know what you said
get your word straight jack
how you doing people i'm dave rubin this
is the reuben report direct message
today is monday march 21st in the year
2022
and that was your president joe biden
he's my president too i admit it at
least he's pretending to be president
that was him a little bit before the
election talking about the laptop and as
you can see being very respectful to a
constituent who was potentially a voter
uh who you know didn't
want to argue with joe biden but asked a
somewhat legitimate question and joe
lost his [ __ ]
that's going to sort of frame what we're
doing with the show today because a lot
of people are lying about an awful lot
of stuff and it's a it's a i would say a
conglomerate between the politicians the
media and big tech and we're gonna
unpack using pictures audio and video
because this is a multi-media
show and of course i should tell you we
are live streaming as always on rumble
youtube and blaze tv if you haven't
subscribed to our rumble channel please
do i sense that youtube is not my future
people so uh reuben report over on
rumble it's just rumble.com ruben report
and uh by the way as you may have heard
i'm going on tour people that don't burn
this country book tour tickets are on
sale now for the general public as we
refer to you fine people i'm going to
give about an hour talk in each one of
these events i'm going to have a little
uh opener with the with a guest i'll
tell you about those in just a second
and then we're gonna do like a moderated
q a for 45 minutes we're gonna do
giveaways i'm gonna mess around with the
crowd every single show will be
different dennis prager will be joining
me in brea california uh megan kelly
will be joining me in west nyack new
york megan mccain in washington d.c
glenn beck will be joining me in dallas
i'm 99 sure that larry elder is joining
me in oxnard california and if i keep
saying it then i know it will happen uh
benny johnson will be joining me in
clearwater florida michael malus the
willy wonka of politics will be joining
me in atlanta georgia andrew clavin from
the daily wire will be joining me in
raleigh north carolina and we'll be
announcing some more people that will be
joining me over the next uh coming days
and weeks if you want to get tickets and
you can get vip tickets where you get to
shake my hand and i said the one second
hug if you want it not the two second
hug we're not doing that you can go to
davereuben.com events and all the
tickets uh come with a book so you get a
book you get a show you'll have some
drinks you have a wonderful evening i
promise you that anyway today's show is
all about the liars the lies that they
tell and the people who protect the
lying liars that's what we're going to
be doing
but before i get to any of that i want
to talk to you guys about helix you know
i recently received my helix mattress
and this thing is soft and cushy and
fantastic helix sleep has a quiz that
takes just two minutes to complete and
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you why buy a mattress made for someone
else with helix you're getting a
mattress that will be perfect for the
way you sleep helix knows that
everybody's unique so they offer several
different mattress models they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattresses
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot mattresses great for spinal
alignment and to prevent morning aches
and pains and even a helix plus for
plus-sized sleepers when i took the quiz
i was matched with the midnight luxe
mattress because it's great for side
sleepers i only sleep on my side there's
a little info about dave rubin do not
sleep on my back cannot do it never
liked it never will so if you're looking
for a mattress take the quiz order your
perfect match and the mattress ships
right to your door for free you don't
even need to go to a mattress store ever
again helix has been recommended by
leading chiropractors and doctors of
sleep medicine as a solution for
improving sleep just go to helix sleep
dot com slash reuben take their two
minute sleep quiz and they'll match you
to a customized mattress that'll give
you the best sleep of your life they
have a 10 year warranty and you get to
try it out for a hundred nights
risk-free helix even has financing
options and flexible payment payment
plans so a great night's sleep is never
far away helix is offering over up to
200 off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com reuben
and now back to me okay
so look people they lie
we know they're lying
they know they're lying they know we
know they're lying and they continue to
lie that is the framework
for today's shows and who are they
well they're the media
there are politicians
they're big tech it's the whole freaking
machine and then they censor when we try
to tell the truth so the reason i wanted
to do this show today and we're mostly
going to be focusing
on hunter biden's laptop and the media
reaction or lack thereof i should say
but the reason i wanted to do it today
is because monday morning is always
interesting because i try not to be
online over the weekend and i try to lay
low on the news kind of stuff and then i
open up my phone monday mornings and
it's like well what the hell is going on
here and the first thing that popped up
on twitter is that babylon b and you
guys know babylon b i've done their
podcast a bunch of times they they're
actually funny
an actual funny thing in 2022 it's very
bizarre they're a satire site uh they
were banned well suspended but
potentially banned i'll explain that in
just a sec on twitter yesterday for this
tweet so let's pull up the tweet here is
their tweet the babylon b and as you can
see they're a blue check verified
twitter account the babylon b's man of
the year is rachel levine and of course
rachel levine
is the what is she the deputy health
secretary or something like that you see
how i used her preferred pronouns for
just a second because i'm trying to be
respectful i always say if someone's
respectful of me i will be respectful of
them i will at least try to do that and
i don't mind you know anyone's entitled
to do whatever they want with with their
body as a consenting adult and all of
that stuff anyway that was their tweet
now the simple truth is that rachel
levine is is trans meaning biologically
male and has transitioned and is living
as a female i don't know if she's had
the full surgery or anything else like
that but that doesn't change your
biology so so she is a man
she is a man i mean this is where the
language all gets silly i i don't want
to get too lost in all of that uh but
anyway regardless of what you think
about trans people regardless of what
you
what rachel levine's full
diagnostic situation is and all that
it's a joke
it's a joke and i'm pretty sure
in a healthy society you're allowed to
make jokes and i'm pretty sure you're
allowed to make jokes about gay people
and black people and trans people and
jews and everyone else by making jokes
we actually show that we're all part of
the thing together right jokes
i'm pretty sure in family guy they've
made some gay jokes i'm pretty sure the
simpsons has made some off-color jokes
or seinfeld or whatever whatever comedy
you like
you know like they've all made jokes
anyway it was a joke and you may not
like the joke but of course that is not
something worth uh being suspended on
twitter for show me the image of there
you go so this was uh posted by the head
of babylon be his name's seth dylan good
guy i've had him on the show once
actually
and he then tweeted out this we're not
deleting anything so basically twitter
said to him if you guys delete the
account we'll suspend you for 12 hours
but if you don't delete the tweet then
we're just not letting you back in he
said we're not deleting anything truth
is not hate speech it's the cost of
telling the truth
uh sorry if the cost of telling the
truth is the loss of our twitter account
then so be it so he's fighting back they
they are not going to delete the tweet i
suspect i suspect that twitter is not
going to back down on this one and this
will be up to the babylon b guys to
decide whether they want that account
back on twitter or not because this is
one of those things where twitter has
laid out their policy you may not like
their policy and their policy is
obviously arbitrary and everything else
but they've said this is what it is you
can't misgender people or be hateful to
these protected classes et cetera et
cetera he's saying he's not going to
back down so so it's pretty interesting
and now why am i talking about this
because obviously one tweet from the
babylon b twitter account and the
banning of a joke in and of itself isn't
the scariest thing possible but i think
you'll see why because i think we can
link all of this to everything that's
happening right now with joe biden
hunter biden the laptop from hell as
donald trump call it and everything else
so now let's look back in october of
2020. this is right before the election
remember we had a presidential election
and the new york post which has been a
newspaper one of the most reputable news
sources we've had in america for over
100 years or so they had this story
about hunter biden's laptop and all the
information that was on their pictures
that were on there and emails and
everything else and they were suspended
for sharing the story connor could you
throw that up one more time so what
you're seeing on the left there is new
york post when they got the info this is
the email that they got saying hey your
account is suspended now what twitter
also did is what you're seeing on the
right
uh
what you're seeing on the right there
which is that if other people
tried to post the links
on their own twitter account to new york
post article uh they were putting
warnings on that the new york post by
the way was founded by a guy by the name
of alexander hamilton
you might want to google him if you
think he was some crazy conspiracy
right-wing maniac okay uh anyway
now we've got censoring of the babylon
bee and if you flash back you know
roughly two years ago we've got them
censoring a story that we all now know
is true but don't take my word for it
here's cbs in salt lake city explaining
exactly what's going on with the hunter
biden laptop
leading up to the 2020 presidential
election the biden campaign hit a
roadblock a new york post report about a
laptop that landed at a delaware repair
shop apparently belonging to the
president's son hunter on that laptop a
trove of emails detailing hunter's
apparent business dealings including an
effort to connect his father then vice
president biden to a ukrainian energy
company where hunter sat on the board
but the effort to suppress the story
came almost immediately social media
outlets began limiting sharing of the
story on their platforms facebook
calling the move an effort to quote
reduce the spread of misinformation then
president-elect biden also waded into
the waters do you still think that the
stories
from the fall about your
but a new york times report this week
confirming the authenticity of the
laptop now over a year removed from the
first report by the new york post the
effort to kill the original story is
under the spotlight
okay so we can all go back and forth and
plenty of people will spend plenty of
time doing it on all of the contents in
the laptop and the importance or
relevance of those emails and whatever
else he had in terms of pictures and all
of that other stuff
but the simple truth is for sure there
are emails in there that are very
obviously real everyone now knows that
they're real we were not allowed to say
they were real a year and a half ago now
they are real even the new york times
admitted it we talked about it last week
and i'll show you that piece again in
just a moment
but not only are they real but it we
have further evidence now that hunter
biden was working for a ukrainian energy
company and basically trying to sell
access to his dad that's the only reason
he was hired he has no expertise in
energy or anything related to ukraine
it's the only reason the guy got the job
when you talk about the swamp when you
talk about nepotism all of these things
that's exactly what happened here and we
weren't allowed to talk about that
before the election like who made the
decision at twitter this is the real
issue
beyond beyond the corruption like
corruption just exists we all know
corruption exists politicians are
corrupt okay fine companies can do all
sorts of things to buy access to
you know give money to politicians to
get policies they want past all of that
the real issue is who at twitter when
this article was breaking who made the
final decision was it jack dorsey the
ceo of twitter who made the final
decision to say we will not let this
article be tweeted out we will suspend
the new york post account do whoever
made that decision whatever emails
that's where we should be looking for
emails that's where we should be looking
for correspondence it's at twitter
really because who's really in charge of
the united states if we can't if there
are certain companies that block the
truth from getting out there and then
those certain companies can also block
say i don't know the president of the
united states from being on their
platforms because then who's really in
charge right that's the real question so
there needs to be some internal
investigations of twitter twitter
obviously is not going to do that if we
had any journalists
let me
if you're a journalist and you're
watching this and you want like the
easiest slam dunk ever that's the story
man don't worry about the emails they'll
the emails and the collusion
and the corruption that shit'll be
revealed okay oh clyde's in studio today
by the way he's down here in case you
hear him shaking it out um
that all of that will be revealed but
the real story is what connections did
the people at twitter have to the
government or the biden administration
it was an administration yet the biden
campaign what connections were there
that they said we will not let this
story get out that's the question
someone do some freaking work would you
do some work and let's just flash back
to what happened last week so now that
we're allowed to talk about this right
it was all a conspiracy theory now we're
allowed to talk about it this was the
new york times last week remember this
is all the stuff that new york post said
a year and a half ago people familiar
with the investigation said prosecutors
had examined emails between mr biden mr
archer and others about barisma and
other foreign business activity those
emails were obtained by the new york
times from a cachet of files that
appears to have come from a laptop
abandoned by mr biden in a delaware
repair shop the email and others in the
cachet were authenticated by people
familiar with them and with the
investigation and some of the emails mr
biden displayed a familiarity with farah
and his desire to avoid triggering it
okay so this is exactly what the new
york post was saying before the election
do you think that this might have
affected the election and is it possible
that the powers that via twitter didn't
want this information to get out because
they really didn't like orange man and
they really did
like joe biden do you think any of that
is possible and it's like if you think
any of that's possible then how can we
trust any of the information that we get
from mainstream media that then gets
filtered through big tech you see where
i'm going with this today people
uh let's we showed you this last week
too but let me just run through it real
quick these were just some of the tweets
the then tweets what these companies
were saying well i'm not going to read
all of them but here's cnn to me this is
just class book soviet russian
tradecraft it worked former director of
national intelligence james clapper says
as authorities are investigating
recently published emails if recently
published emails are tied to a russian
disinformation effort targeting biden
and then we've got more there connor you
could just fly through them npr said it
was misinformation joy ann reed from the
mental institution it was misinformation
politico more than 50 senior
intelligence officials kyle griffin from
msnbc they all wanted to make sure
here's ben rhodes part of the obama
administration they all guys and there's
a gajillion more of those but they just
wanted you to make sure this thing is a
lie a lot of very important people said
it's a lie and we shouldn't be able to
see that lie the people who lied about
everything did not want you to see the
lie that turned out to be true
but if our pictures i promised you guys
uh pictures video and audio today uh if
the pictures that we just showed you the
text of what these people are saying is
not enough here's a little video
compilation of media pundits and talking
heads
lying
and lie
biden secret emails a really fishy story
the post claimed that the emails were
found on a laptop computer that was
brought to a repair shop in delaware in
the spring of 2019. the fbi is now
investigating whether those alleged
underbide emails are actually connected
to a larger foreign intelligence
operation they may be related to a
foreign intelligence operation foreign
intelligence operation foreign
intelligence foreign intelligence
foreign intelligence operations for all
we know these emails are made up the
information found on the laptop may be
part of a russian disinformation
campaign part of a russian
disinformation
effort described by many intelligence
experts as having hallmarks all the
hallmarks rather all the hallmarks of a
russian russian russian disinformation
russian disinformation disinformation
campaign this is a classic example of
the right-wing media machine
i like the lady in the mask the most you
know like you're on television not
sitting near anyone are you clowns
anyway you can really see how lies just
get laundered through the system right
you can just see it how then all of
these people who are supposed to be
journalists who are supposed to be the
fourth estate they're supposed to be
protecting us from the powers that be
right they're supposed to be making sure
that we
the citizens are informed properly about
the goings-on of the people that are in
charge but they actually do the complete
reverse they do the complete reverse i
mean brian stelter okay you got busted
man you're busted are you going to have
your maya culpa and say boy i really
went in all on this scandal and it turns
out everything that i reported on about
trump and russia and the laptop being
fake and everybody else ah
i'm an idiot i'm either an idiot i'm
either a willful idiot because it felt
it fit the narrative that i liked or i'm
a propagandist like pick one potato uh
here's video of joe biden right before
the election
and he's very indignant that it's all
nonsense this whole thing we showed you
this one the other day too but i'm
building a case here like a prosecutor
people
so what about the americans who really
today only want me to ask you about
hunter biden's laptop how are you going
to get them to see
that you are fighting for them when
they're so
against you
there's nothing to any of that
nothing to that it's all a smear
every major outfit every serious
investigator has pointed out
that this is a smear
this is classic trump
we have four days left and all of a
sudden there's a laptop and you may
recall there's also talk about
four months before there was a similar
thing that somebody had allegedly
there's overwhelming evidence that from
the intelligence community that the
russians are engaged i mean look this is
my son's an honorable man
and all the investigations that were
done around the issue of what was going
on in ukraine if you notice
every one of the major people who work
for trump
during the impeachment went under oath
and under oath said biden did his job
no law was providing this biden did his
job hunter biden broke no laws that was
the testimony
their testimony from republicans and
intelligence community people
i mean i just don't even know what
planet that guy is on everything he said
there is a lie every single thing he
said there his son is an honorable man
even he's a crack addict no offense to
crack addicts um but he said every major
outlet this is how you see the the lies
get laundered he knows that the major
outlets are working for him so when they
say hey is the laptop real he says well
every major outlet says it isn't real
yes because the major outlets either
cover
uh for you or lie about it or ignore the
story entirely then he also says every
serious investigator what he's referring
to there is the 50
uh intelligence officials who all said
this was russian misinformation and now
it turns out to be true because the
whole freaking swamp lives to protect
the swamp
i don't mean to be a dick about it it
just is i'm not even it just is it just
is and you really have to understand
that and then of course he calls it
classic trump it's classic trump to make
up all of this stuff if by classic trump
he means oh somebody actually telling
the truth somehow pushing out some level
of truth through all of this insanity
then i guess that is classic trump uh
here's classic trump hitting joe biden
about the laptop during one of the
debates in 2020
russia ukraine china other countries
iraq if this is true then he's a corrupt
politician right so don't give me the
stuff about how you're this innocent
baby joe they're calling you a corrupt
politician nobody president trump i want
to stay on the issue of racism we're
talking about
from hell president trump we're talking
about race right now and i do want to
stay on the issue of race president
trump i have to respond to that please
look very clear there are 50 former
national intelligence folks
who said that what this he's accusing me
of is a russian plan
they have said that this is has all the
care four five former heads of the cia
both parties say what he's saying is a
bunch of garbage
nobody believes it except of his and his
good friend rudy gianni you mean the
laptop is now another russia russia
russia hoax that's exactly what this was
exactly what this is where he's going
the laptop is russia
russia i want to stay on the issue of
race you have to be kidding me here we
go again with russia we're going to
continue on the issue of race
not only does biden just lie about
everything indignantly lie about
everything but then he besmirched the
good name of rudy giulia
you know and that's a good man rudy
he's a good guy that guy um i'm kidding
i like rudy giuliani he is a good man
and i lived in new york during 9 11 and
he saved that city um
okay let's just back up for a second why
would hunter biden a crack addict be on
the board of barisma a ukrainian energy
company if you have no expertise in that
field do you think it might be because
his dad was vice president of the united
states at that point and that's what
these emails are all about so everything
that joe biden said there was an
absolute lie he then also references
once again the 50 former intelligence
officials who if you saw the cover we
should have grabbed it maybe we'll grab
it for tomorrow the new york post just
in the last two or three days they put
up all 50 pictures of these people
basically said they all made it up
there's no evidence none of them pointed
to any evidence that the laptop was a
russian misinformation campaign they
just said it right because they like
they like biden and they don't like
trump so everything joe biden said there
is a lie but don't listen to me calling
it a lie it's the new york times now
admitting that the laptop is legit so we
shall continue here is jen sake this is
white house press secretary jen saki but
this is before she got the gig doing
that oh you know what we'll do this one
first actually uh this is a video of 60
minutes this is right before the
election and here's orange man once
again
trying to tell people that something
might be legit about the laptop
and you think it's the biggest issue to
campaign on i think it's this i think
it's one of the biggest scandals i've
ever seen and you don't cover it
you want to talk about it well because
it can't be verified we want to talk
about insignificant things i'm telling
you of course it can be verified excuse
me they found the laptop leslie
marathon
what can't be verified the laptop why do
you say that even the family has
the family on the
laptop
he's gone into hiding for five days he's
gone into hiding he's preparing for your
debate oh it's taken him five days to
prepare i doubt it i did it okay all
right
you know i keep saying this thing about
when you're telling the truth it's just
obvious i can't believe we're at the
point where it's like trump is obviously
the one telling the truth someone who
obviously is over the top and a braggart
and you know uses language in a very odd
way sometimes and all that stuff but he
is more of a truth teller than any of
these people uh the line there when he
says well why aren't you running a story
on it it can't be verified that's what
leslie stahl says now i didn't watch 60
minutes last night i think 60 minutes is
on on sunday nights on cbs if i'm not
mistaken i got a thumbs up over there
okay fine i don't have regular cable tv
anymore um
but now that it has been verified by the
new york times leslie stahl in 60
minutes did you cover it last night can
we find out guys can we do a little
crack research on what 60 minutes
covered last night that'll be funny tell
me things that 60 minutes covered last
night if possible we'll see if we can
get to that in just a second but i'm
guessing they didn't now it has been
verified she said we didn't cover it
because it wasn't verified well now it's
been verified lady
you get it guys you get it and now
to jen sake this is before she was uh
white house press secretary this is what
she said on twitter hunter biden's story
is russian disinformation dozens of
former intel officials say
well
that turns out not to be true if
anything you lady
are spreading disinformation oh and look
at this i got what they covered on 60
minutes last night very exciting they
covered russia obviously high rent
across the united states and something
about the wnba which i assume three or
four years from now will be all men uh
so just a lot of nonsense you guys get
it uh but saki and as i said that was
before
she was press secretary cause that was
right before the biden administration
took over uh she now is the press
secretary and she she just lies about
everything and she looks soulless like
she's
just deeply wounded inside so that is
the silver lining to this thing because
eventually it does come get you all the
lies uh here she is responding to that
very tweet and that excuse about oh the
intelligence officials said it was you
know not real so you know okay good the
president has said and you have tweeted
that allegations of wrongdoing based on
files pulled from hunter biden's laptop
are russian disinformation there is a
new book by politico reporter that finds
some of the files on there are genuine
is the white house still going with
russian disinformation i think it's
broadly known and widely known peter
that there was a broad range of russian
disinformation back in 2020
okay
there was a broad range of russian
disinformation well she said
specifically that those guys said the
biden laptop
was russian disinformation but that
turns out to be untrue and and what are
you saying that the election was meddled
with have you have you done anything to
protect the election
since then i mean she's just
an endless liar uh but it continued at
the press conference because the press
is starting to get some balls i don't
know where the balls are coming from but
they're starting to grow a pair and here
uh the questioner was asking about
biden's conflicts of interest with
russia
on russia you told me last year that you
were unfamiliar with the senate report
that alleged that the first son or a
company linked to the first son received
3.5 million dollars from the richest
woman in russia a subsequent reporting
indicates that president biden when he
was vice president had a dinner in
georgetown with the same woman in 2015.
this uh yelling about arena she has not
been sanctioned yet by the us government
how is president biden navigating
conflicts of interest when it comes to
sanctioning people who have done
business with his family and can you
explain to us what this 3.5 million
dollars was for i don't have any
confirmation of the accuracy of that
report so i have no more further details
about the conflicts of interest that how
he's navigating those when deciding
sanctions what would be his conflicts of
interest well his son's company
allegedly got 3.5 million which i have
no confirmation of and he's continued to
sanction oligarchs more than we've ever
sanctioned in the past so i'm not sure
that's a conflict of interest
i can't stand there did you get what's
happening there so you know we're
sanctioning these russian oligarchs so
this is sort of the super rich class
that lives in russia these are the
people you see they've got yachts and
because they have yachts and they're
rich they must all be evil people i'm
not certainly not defending people that
did anything through corruption but we
are sanctioning all of these russian
oligarchs but you know what's
interesting you're not going to believe
this guys
the uh the journalist was right this
woman that gave 3.5 million to one of
the companies that uh hunter biden was
working for her name is elena batterina
and she's a russian oligarch but
for some reason she's not being targeted
by the sanctions according to and you're
not going to believe it your brain is
going to explode
the new york post
so i assume we won't be able to say that
soon enough and then the new york times
will report on it here you really get
that some really super crazy rich
russian woman gave hunter biden's
company 3.5 million dollars why'd she do
it i don't know um but that woman is not
being targeted by sanctions uh as all
the oligarchs are all the oligarchs are
and they're going after everybody else
really makes you wonder
anyway guys i wanted to do this show and
and do it the way i did on this monday
because
it doesn't matter if you care that much
about this level of corruption or you
you think that all politicians are
corrupt and you think that the
mainstream media is evil and you think
it's being fueled
by big tech and and that we're stuck
we're all stuck
in this game of misinformation and and
what we can see and when we can see it
and people that get things right two
years ago are destroyed and then people
who are late to the party are applauded
for it
all of that stuff it frames everything
it frames everything it frames not just
this story about hunter biden and
ukraine but maybe it frames a little bit
of what's going on with russia and
ukraine right now why is it becoming the
center of the universe right now do you
think it has something to do with this
maybe maybe it does i'm not telling you
i've got the full piece together right
all the pieces but the pieces of the
puzzle are all on the table and you can
start putting them together sometimes
but then big tech comes in and then the
media comes in and they're constantly
shaking the table so the the puzzle
pieces always fall apart right that's
that's how it is but i think related to
what's going on in russia and ukraine
all of the covid stuff and all of the
things that we found out were lies way
later it's like man if you've figured
out a way to not go nut through all of
this right i give you a lot of credit
and it doesn't mean you're going to be
right along the way on every single
thing
but if you remember a little bit of what
the old world is if you remember a
little bit about what truth is and if
you keep your eye on that it's got to be
better than what they're selling us and
as we roll into
the midterm elections as it you can feel
it again like they're about to start
some covid thing again or it's going to
start right before the midterms or
whatever it's like we really have to be
wary about all this there was another
story i saw this morning that the cdc
is now telling their employees that they
have to be better with statistics going
forward it's like oh did you guys lie
about all the statistics too and fouchy
lying about everything so
that's my mission my mission now going
forward is
it's been my mission i guess already but
something about this hunter biden story
it's all so obvious if you if you just
want to see it but i i guess a lot of
people don't want to see it because
you got to live your life and you got to
have a job and hopefully
have somebody that loves you and maybe
have a family and get out there and do
whatever gives you some joy in the mess
so you just turn away you just hope that
the system will just not be totally evil
but it's like something is seriously
seriously wrong here and this is a this
is a really important warning for the
2022 elections what other things are
they gonna lie about you know like they
lied they lied and then banned people
and suspended people for telling the
truth about this they've made the good
guys look like bad guys remember that's
what they do with everything it was only
a month and a half ago we were all had
three days of joe rogan's the biggest
racist in america
they keep getting our eye off the ball
on things while they are the ones who
are usually doing the bad things and we
can't let
the democrats and the media people and
big tech get away with it we can't if
you want to live freely maybe you don't
or maybe you're afraid but i think your
fear is is the fuel for these guys um
and as i always say it doesn't mean that
the republicans are that great but they
ain't democrats and that's worth
something uh guys one more time i want
to remind you that uh oh you know what
before we do that
before we do that it's me monday over at
the reuben report uh locals community
can we throw the meme up today this is
what i threw up today this is kids in
2050 trying to study the 2019 to 2022
chapter of history uh
for a test i mean it's just it's just
perfect like how is anyone you feel bad
for adults like what do you think kids
are going through right now it's just
insanity uh reminder guys the tour it's
coming and i want to see you guys i know
the vip tickets are going real fast uh
especially we have a disproportionate
amount of vip tickets being sold right
now orlando april 18th oh we got a cold
clothes for you today that i think
you're going to really dig i just want
to get through this real quick uh
orlando april 18th uh west palm on the
19th clearwater florida on the 20th
raleigh north carolina april 21st
atlanta georgia with michael malus on
the 22nd chicago on the 23rd dallas with
glenn beck on the 24th of april
washington dc with megan uh mccain on
april 25th
uh april 26 west nyack new york with
megyn kelly dennis prager will be
joining me on may 11th in brea
california i believe i've put it into
the universe and i just need final text
confirmation that larry elder the man
who should be governor of california on
may 12th in oxnard uh may 15th san jose
california may uh 16th we'll be in
phoenix arizona and may 18th in denver
and i'll be adding more of the special
guests and all that good stuff and i
promise you it's just going to be fun
the point of the show will be fun i
promise you if you come and you're ready
to have a good time and have a couple
drinks and laugh and shoot the [ __ ] you
will leave in a better mood than than
when you got there that is my that is
the dave rubin 100
guarantee if you want tickets you can go
to davereuben.com
events by the way guys my full episode
with former ambassador u.s ambassador in
germany rick grinnell is up on locals
right now
and we thought this would be a perfect
cold close if you want a perfect example
of how the media
reacted to the hunter biden story
the meme makers of the internet
[Music]
um
[Music]
you